THINK WE'LL PROBABLY BE TALKING
ABOUT FOR A WHILE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE'LL CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION.
STAY RIGHT THERE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT TEXAS FOR A
MOMENT.
WHERE TRUMP'S ELECTION LIES GOT
A STEP CLOSER TO BECOMING AN
OFFICIAL PART OF THE REPUBLICAN
PLATFORM.
AGAIN, THIS HAPPENED IN TEXAS
THIS WEEKEND AT THE GOP
CONVENTION IN HOUSTON.
LET'S GO TO CNN POLITICS
REPORTER AND EDITOR AT LARGE
CHRIS.
CHRIS, WALK US THROUGH THIS.
>> YEAH.
SO FIRST TO NOTE, THE TEXAS
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAD NOT
MET FORMALLY SINCE 2016.
LET'S START WITH SOME OF WHAT IS
IN THE REPUBLICAN PLATFORM THAVS
THAT WAS APPROVEED THIS WEEKEND.
ALL THIS HAS TO BE FORMALIZED
LATER, BUT IT WILL BE.
THAT BIDEN WAS NOT LEGITIMATELY
ELECTED.
I'M GOING TO WRITE THIS.
IT'S IMPORTANT.
NOT TRUE.
THAT SAYS NOT TRUE.
THEY REBUKE THE TEN GOP SENATORS
WHO HAVE BACKED THE GOVERNMENT
REFORM BILL.
TALKING ABOUT THE TEXT, WHAT
THEY'LL DO, BUT THAT INCLUDES
RIGHT HERE, THAT INCLUDES JOHN
CORNYN OF TEXAS.
I'M GOING TO GET BACK TO HIM.
AND THEY DECLARE HOMOSEXUALITY
AN ABNORMAL LIFESTYLE CHOICE.
THAT'S THE PLATFORM, WHAT THEY
DID.
NOW, HERE'S SOME OF WHAT THEY
SAID.
LET'S PLAY IT.
THIS IS ABOUT JOHN CORNYN,
SENATOR FROM TEXAS.
AND DAN CRENSHAW, MEMBER OF
CONGRESS FROM TEXAS.
BOTH REPUBLICANS.
LET'S PLAY THAT.
>> McCAIN, HEY, EYE PATCH
McCAIN.
LOOK AT EYE PATCH McCAIN RIGHT
HERE.
YOU'RE A GLOBALIST RYE RINO.
YOU'RE A GLOBALIST RINO.
EYE PATCH McCAIN.
>> SO LET'S JUST PUT A LITTLE
CONTEXT ON IT.
THE GUY SCREAMING EYE PATCH
McCAIN AT DAN CRENSHAW, I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT GUY KNEW THIS OR
NOT, BUT LET'S EDUCATE HIM.
DAN CRENSHAW LOST HIS EYE WHILE
SERVING IN AFGHANISTAN.
SO THERE'S THAT.
THERE'S ALSO THAT INCREDIBLY
AWKWARD THING THAT POLITICIANS
OCCASIONALLY HAVE TO ENDURE
WHERE YOU SAW JOHN CORNYN IN THE
FIRST CLIP.
THEY'RE JUST BOOING, AND HE HAS
THAT, LIKE, PLEASE, LET THIS END
SMILE ON HIS FACE.
SO YOU CAN SEE THIS SPEAKS TO
THE FACT NEITHER OF THESE GUYS
ARE MODERATES AT ALL, AND YET,
THEY'RE BEING BOOED.
THEY'RE BEING CAJOLED.
THEY'RE BEING BULLIED AT THEIR
OWN PARTY'S CONVENTION.
IT'S REMARKABLE.
>> AND SO SO MUCH OF THE GOP IS
ON THIS EXTREME END.
>> YEAH.
>> OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM,
BUT THE RADICALIZING ISN'T JUST
HAPPENING IN TEXAS.
RIGHT?
TELL US ABOUT THIS DISTURBING
NEW CAMPAIGN RHETORIC FROM A
REPUBLICAN SENATE CANDIDATE AND
FORMER GOVERNOR IN MISSOURI.
>> SO I OFTEN SAY I'VE LOST THE
ABILITY TO BE TOTALLY SHOCKED IN
COVERING POLITICS, BUT WHEN I
SAW THIS VIDEO POP UP THIS
MORNING, I WAS SOMEWHAT SHOCKED.
IT'S ERIK GRIETENS WHO RESIGNED
IN DISGRACE AMID SEXUAL ASSAULT
ALLEGATIONS.
HE'S DENIED THEM.
HE POSTED -- THIS IS THE START
YOU'RE SEEING.
THIS IS THE START OF THE AD.
HE'S WALKING DOWN WHAT LOOKS
LIKE A SUBURBAN STREET WITH A
LONG GUN.
HE COBS AND SAYS IT'S TIME TO GO
RINO HUNTING.
THEN WITH A TACTICAL TEAM, THEY
BASH THE DOOR DOWN, AND THEY SAY
THERE'S NO TAGGING AND BAGGING
LIMIT, AND WE WON'T STOP UNTIL
WE END THEIR BLAH BLAH BLAH
BLAH.
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE SEEN FROM THE
LIKES OF ADAM KINZINGER
YESTERDAY SAYING VIOLENCE IS A
REAL POSSIBILITY, I'VE HAD
THREATS MADE TO ME AND MY
FAMILY.
GIVEN THE RHETORIC AND HOW IT
PLAYED OUT ON JANUARY 6TH, IT IS
A REMARKABLE THING.
AND MOST DEPRESSINGLY, IT WILL
PROBABLY WORK.
IT HAD 180,000 VIEWS.
HE'LL USE IT TO RAISE MONEY.
BUT WHETHER IT WORKS OR NOT
DOESN'T MEAN WHETHER IT'S RIGHT
OR NOT.
AND IT'S CLEARLY NOT.
>> TIME TO GO RINO HUNTING.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HE SAID THAT.
CHRIS, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> FOR YOUR REPORTING.
ANDREW IS BACK WITH US.
BEN IS BACK WITH US.
ADAM KINZINGER GOT A DEATH
THREAT SENT TO HIS HOUSE.
WE HEARD HIM WARN MORE POLITICAL
VIOLENCE IS ON THE WAY.
NOW YOU HAVE A MISSOURI SENATE
CANDIDATE CALLING FOR MODERATE
REPUBLICANS, AKA, RINOS, TO BE
HUNTED.
HOW CONCERNING IS THIS MOMENT,
AND HOW CAN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ADDRESS THAT KIND OF
DANGEROUS RHETORIC WHEN IT COMES
FROM PROMINENT POLITICIANS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THINK YOU
USE THE PERFECT WORD EARLIER
WHEN YOU REFERRED TO IT AS
RADICALIZATION.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE.
IT JUST SO HAPPENS TO BE TAKING
PLACE NOT IN A FOREIGN TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION OR AMONG A FRINGE
RIGHT WING GROUPS.
THEY PUT IN PLACE A MAJOR
POLITICAL PARTY.
REPUBLICANS, YOU SAW THE VIDEO
FROM THE REPUBLICAN CONVENTION
IN TEXAS AND NOW YOU HAVE THIS
RUNNING FOR OFFICE AS A
REPUBLICAN.
IT'S NOT THE CONGRESSMAN WHO IS
WARNING THAT POLITICAL VIOLENCE
IS LIKE LAY.
WE GOT A SIMILAR WARNING FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY JUST A WEEK AGO.
AND IT IS WELL-KNOWN THAT
EXTREMISTS USE THESE SORTS OF
PERCEIVED GRIEVANCES TO FUEL THE
HATRED, THE ANGER THAT
ULTIMATELY ERUPTS IN ACTS OF
VIOLENCE.
SO FOR PEOPLE IN -- OR MAYBE I
SHOULD SAY FORMERLY IN POSITIONS
OF PUBLIC TRUST AND IN POLITICS
LIKE THE FORMER GOVERNOR TO SAY
THINGS THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE
VIOLENCE OR THE HUNTING OF
POLITICAL OPPONENTS, IT'S JUST
UNBELIEVABLY DANGEROUS AND
IRRESPONSIBLE.
WHAT CAN YOU DO ABOUT THAT
RHETORIC?
VERY, VERY LITTLE.
THAT RHETORIC IS PROTECTED AS
FIRST AMENDMENT PROTECTED SPEECH
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO IT'S -- IT'S REALLY UP TO
PEOPLE THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE AND
TO TEMPER THAN OWN RHETORIC
WHICH SEEMS TO BE SOMETHING THAT
NO ONE IS DOING ANYMORE.
>> AND I'M THINKING ABOUT THE
VIDEOS AT A COUPLE OF THE
HEARINGS WHERE YOU HEAR DIRECTLY
FROM INSURRECTIONISTS WHO SAY I
CAME HERE BECAUSE TRUMP TOLD ME
TO COME.
PEOPLE ARE LISTENING TO THESE
POLITICIANS AND ARE TAKING THEIR
CUES FROM THEM.
HOW DANGEROUS IS IT THAT TRUMP'S
FALSE ELECTION CONSPIRACY IS
ABOUT TO BECOME THE OFFICIAL
PLATFORM OF THE GOP IN TEXAS?
>> IT'S VERY DISTURBING THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING.
IT'S A TIME WHEN THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE ITSELF SHOULD
STEP UP AND SAY IT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE STATE
PARTIES OR GOVERNOR'S CANDIDATES
SAYING SUCH THINGS.
THEY ARE A SPIRITED GROUP, AND
THEY NOT REPRESENT EVEN TODAY
THE MAINSTREAM OF THE TEXAS
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
JOHN CORNYN AND DAN CRENSHAW ARE
THE ELECTED OFFICIALS, AND THEY
GOT THERE BY GETTING ELECTED.
NOBODY IN THAT CONVENTION DID.
IN TERMS OF -- THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL LEADERSHIP KNOWS THAT
IT WOULD BE BAD FOR REPUBLICANS
TO HAVE GRIETENS AS THE NOMINEE,
AND MITCH McCONNELL'S SUPERPAC,
AND OTHER NATIONAL GROUPS ARE
BACKING OTHER CANDIDATES IN
HOPES THAT GRIETENS DOES GET
DEFEATED N BUT THE LARGER POINT
IS THAT DONALD TRUMP'S RHETORIC
HAS CAUSED AN UP TICK IN
VIOLENCE, AND AS ANDY SAID, IS
100% RIGHT.
REALLY DISTURBING.
DONALD TRUMP HAD HIS DAY IN
COURT.
HE LOST ALL BUT ONE OF THE 64
CASES HE BROUGHT.
HE HAD HIS DAY IN COURT.
>> ELECTION FRAUD CLAIMS.
>> YES, WITH THE ELECTION FRAUD
CLAIMS, AND TO CONTINUE WITH THE
RHETORIC WHEN WE COULDN'T
PRODUCE EVIDENCE AND COULDN'T
WIN IN COURT, PUTS THE COUNTRY
IN